you know what we are we're noodling with
the configuration of atlanta as we speak
andy cohen dishes on the shake-ups to
the cast of the real housewives of
atlanta orange county and new york i
loved it i thought it was amazing e.t
caught up with the executive producer of
the hit franchise to talk about his new
peacock series x-rated and when asked if
the rumors that atlanta housewives
porsha williams and cynthia bailey might
be out of the lineup and franchise og
cheray whitfield could return and he
pulled a piece of paper out of his
garbage at his desk and teased this
i just threw out a little piece of paper
that has the names of who i believe the
cast come on we can wait we can wait
andy dig in there
there are six names on this list
six names would mean there's one more
wife than season 13 which featured
porsha cynthia candy burris kenya moore
and drew sedora and while that number is
all the watch what happens live host was
willing to offer up when it came to an
update andy did confess that he wants to
see cheray back on the small screen when
asked which former housewives from any
city he'd like to bring back to tv she
last appeared as a cast member in season
10 which finished airing in 2018.
i always loved sheree i mean we just
brought heather dubrow back in orange
county and i thought that was great i
think it would be fun to bring someone
back that no one i mean people talk
about
the rinda or lisa vanderpump or you know
i think i always like the curveball and
the people saying what you're bringing
back this person
um i think monique would be fun in
potomac
bravo announced in june that heather
would return to the show for season 16
after exiting the series in 2016. and
andy previously opened up to et about
the decision to bring her back to the
cast of the oc saying that it was a
quote great time to get back to some of
the aspirational luxury that the orange
county franchise launched with and that
heather certainly represents
either gibral this is very famous you
love champagne do you literally know
anyone else with a champagne wall
um i know people that have it now after
seeing it in my house i will tell you
that
um oh but um you know imitation is
flattering a sincerest form
heather's return came with the news that
kelly dodd bronwyn wyndham burke and
elizabeth lynn vargas were all let go
from the show leaving just shannon
storm's badour emily simpson and gina
kirschenheiter it's really fun bravo is
expected to confirm more casting for the
upcoming season before it launches
likely later this year or early 2022 and
bands are holding out hope that tamara
judge may pop up as a friend of the main
cast i mean it's amazing tamara stepped
away from the show in early 2020 after
declining a contract to return in a
limited capacity for the 15th season and
even andy would like to see it telling
e.t tamra was quote one of the greats
adding quote i hope at some point either
now or in the future we'll do more with
her cheers to tammy and cheers to tamara
then there's the real housewives of new
york city which has been met with
lackluster ratings and fan response this
season
andy weighed in on that too explaining
that they shot the show during the kovid
19 pandemic when the world was shut down
adding that real housewives of new york
city is reliant on new york city as a
character itself within the show
but is a cast shakeup looming andy tells
et quote i think that if anything we
should add to the group because i think
people wanted to see more people i
really don't want you to think i don't
trust you it's not about that it's about
actually protecting our friendship
honestly
the current lineup includes ramona
singer and fellow og cast member luanne
de la seps long time star sonia morgan
and relative newbies leah mcsweeney and
ebony k williams who joined in seasons
12 and 13 respectively for now it looks
like fans will just have to wait and see
but until then we know one thing for
sure the ladies of the real housewives
franchise will keep us fully
you're going to do is act entertained a
stupid ass clown
don't talk to her like that really don't
i've had enough a brush on
you